nous avions visé 12 16 ans et non pas 16
18 ans nous avions exclu 16 18 ans parce
que à partir de 16 ans on a la
possibilité de se faire vacciner sans
l'accord de ses parents et c'est vrai
que
l'argument qui consistait à nous dire
que 80 % des
adolescents étaient déjà vaccinées des
douze saisons et que donc le restant les
autres adolescents non vaccinés était
vraisemblablement des enfants dedans
ti'vac sous des enfants de parents qui
ne souhaitait pas faire vacciner leurs
enfants
et que ce serait sans doute une manière
de mettre un peu la pression ça nous est
apparu
difficile à accepter parce que c'est une
instruments il une instrumentalisation
et puis parce que ça n'est pas très
éthique mes chers collègues nous sommes
mis d'accord sur l'intérêt de l'enfant
dans l'hémicycle le gouvernement nous a
entendus à proposer eux nous a proposé
une rédaction une rédaction n'est jamais
parfaite mais c'est un cadre un monsieur
le ministre vous l'avez dit ensuite le
décret précisera mais c'est une
rédaction qui préserve à la fois la
santé des mineurs la santé de tous les
français et évidemment la nécessité pour
les adolescents de pouvoir participer
aux activités sportives et culturelles
nous voulons
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le groupe
agir ensemble votera pour cet amendement
celui des dames travaillèrent ainsi que
pour le sous-amendement du gouvernement
nous pensons en effet il ya que les
parents sont évidemment libres de
vacciner ou de ne pas vacciner leurs
enfants ou leurs adolescents et que un
adolescent dans une famille où les
parents ne souhaitent pas le faire
vacciner évidemment n'a pas de choix il
est quelque part contraint de suivre le
choix de ses parents et donc il nous
paraissait injuste que les enfants qui
sont dans des familles qu'ils ne
souhaitent pas les vaccinés souhaite
ainsi écarté des activités périscolaires
ou extra scolaire privé d'aller à leur
club de sport priver d'aller à leur
cours de musique ou à d'autres activités
culturelles et donc nous pensons que cet
amendement est ce sous-amendement et
bien restaure cette justice la capacité
pour les enfants pour les adolescents de
continuer à avoir accès à l'ensemble de
ses activités même s'ils ne sont pas
vaccinés parce qu'ils se seront testés
merci madame intermédiaire
[Musique]
monsieur monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des lois d'abord je tiens à
vous remercier monsieur le ministre
d'avoir accepté d'écouter finalement nos
demandes s'est jamais simple
effectivement pour un gouvernement je
tiens vraiment à remercier madame la
présidente de la commission des lois qui
a suscité en fait ce travail collectif
et c'est important pour le parlement de
pouvoir quelquefois atterrir ensemble
sur un sujet aussi majeur que le que
celui de la jeunesse je remercie bien
sûr marc fesneau qui a souhaité aussi
que le parlement existe vraiment dans ce
texte il y a beaucoup de dispositions
qui ne nous conviennent pas encore mais
vous le savez en revanche atterrir tous
ensemble sur la question de la jeunesse
ça me paraît tout à fait essentiel nous
serons tous heureux soulagé dans notre
circonscription de pouvoir dire aux
familles que nous avons tous ensemble et
je remercie l'ensemble des chefs de
groupe des présidents de groupes pardon
qui ont qui ont manifesté déjà leur
accord pouvoir venir et leur dire que
nous avons eu le souci que ceux ci
puissent bénéficier encore d'une vie
quasi normale malgré une crise sanitaire
extrêmement prégnante je retiens les
propos du ministre à savoir que la
vaccination est une nécessité néanmoins
pour tous et une volonté très forte
affichée par nous aussi le groupe
socialiste vous le savez tout cas
vraiment merci merci pour la genèse de
cet effort qui a été fait
monsieur dupont-aignan qui prenait d'un
aspect
oui monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre quel hypocrisie
à la belle séance la belle séance au
service de la jeunesse quelle générosité
un test sera maintenu tous les 24 heures
alors vous savez
cela me paraît un petit cadeau alors
bien sûr je m'en réjouis c'est mieux que
rien mais mais franchement ne dit pas
que c'est pour la jeunesse cette
jeunesse que vous enfermez cette
jeunesse que vous obliger à la
vaccination alors que les bénéfices sont
inférieurs aux risques et c'est ça la
réalité
regardez ce qui est écrit l' agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament
regardez ce qu'écrit l' agence
américaine regardez ce qu'écrit l'
agence européenne et les conséquences
graves pour nos jeunes les conséquences
cardiaques les conséquences graves les
morts pour un bénéfice extrêmement
réduit extrêmement réduit on est
alors oui pour les personnes fragiles
les personnes âgées tout le monde
reconnaît le bénéfice individuel de la
vaccination j'ai toujours reconnu en
revanche pour les jeunes pour les jeunes
et les enfants quand vous regardez le
nombre de cas précis quand vous regardez
les avertissements de toutes les
autorités de santé officiel allez sur
les sites et bien vous verrez que le
bénéfice risque n'existe pas et c'est
pourquoi vous devez laisser libre notre
jeunesse d'affronter avec son immunité
naturelle excepté les cas
la parole est un même panneau
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre de deux remarques préalables la
première que et ça c'est pour répondre à
monsieur gouffier châssis il est rare
dans cet hémicycle de trouver des
accords même à minima et je souscris pas
à ce qui a été dit par les collègues les
républicains que nous devons avoir un
vrai débat sur cette question là il
parle des baora b qui se serait terminé
à 6h 7h ou 8h du matin deuxième remarque
préalable il se trouve que vous venez
d'où avec cet amendement cet amendement
même à minima que la défenseur des
droits avait raison de dire que ce
n'était pas proportionnée de faire une
obligation vaccinale déguisés pour les
mineurs ll 10 jusqu'à 18 ans vous dites
jusqu'à 16 ans et que ce n'était pas
proportionnée parce que c'était une
atteinte aux droits notamment à la
culture et aux loisirs qui est un droit
proclamée par la convention
internationale relative aux droits de
l'enfant et que par ailleurs dans le
cadre extrascolaire cela donnait lieu à
une stigmatisation de l'élève non
vaccinés preuve que la défenseur des
droits avait raison et que vous ferez
bien de l'écouter un peu plus souvent
deuxième remarque troisième chose
évidemment nous allons prendre nous
allons prendre ce qui ne veut pas dire
que nous sommes d'accord avec le pass à
iter ou avec le pass vaccinale mais nous
allons voter ce sous amendement qui
permet un petit mieux mais monsieur le
ministre est là j'attire votre attention
vous nous avez donné des chiffres
malheureusement malheureusement le bilan
du coc vide n'est pas uniquement sur le
nombre d'hospitaliser ni même
malheureusement sur le nombre de morts
est le l'hôpital robert debré je vais
juste terminée là dessus a alerté sur
l'augmentation des tentatives de suicide
chez les moins de 15 ans plus de 100 99
% donc il va falloir arrêter de faire
souffrir la jeunesse comme vous le
faites mathieu gimel à la parole
[Applaudissements]
oui bien sûr oui j'ai dit monsieur
jumelles
sur la forme nous avons la démonstration
qu'ils auraient dû inspirer le
gouvernement depuis plusieurs mois qu à
plusieurs têtes nous réfléchissons mieux
que d'autres dans une seule
sur le fond maintenant
il est heureux que l'intérêt supérieur
de l'enfant les emporter sur tout le
reste et donc je me félicite de se
bouger
qui va tranquilliser les familles alors
c'est un petit bougé il ne faut pas non
plus mais qu'il va tranquilliser les
familles sur la forme toujours j'aurais
été nous aurions été sensible monsieur
le ministre à ce que les chiffres que
vous avez donné tout à l'heure sur
devant la représentation nationale vous
puissiez nous les données avant parce
que là aussi sur la gestion de crise
nous éclairait sur les données
objectives est aussi une aide utile à la
décision partagée et à la décision
collective sur le fond désormais même si
nous allons évidemment nous féliciter de
se bouger
positif je perds jamais de vue que la
sédentarité des enfants est un élément
de leur obésité que l'obésité des
enfants est un élément qui nuit à leur
santé et donc les pratiques sportives
les pratiques qui vise à recréer du lien
sont évidemment positive mais qu' il
sera toujours exigé non pas pour les
enfants des antilles vax mais pour les
enfants éloignés la république ou
indifférents à la crise sanitaire quand
on est môme on se croit immortel on a
tous été je crois habité par ce
sentiment là et donc ne pas stigmatiser
les enfants n'ont plus selon leur
appartenance ou selon les choix de leurs
parents ces enfants là méritent aussi de
pouvoir pratiquer les activités
sportives culturelles avec leurs copains
en classe avec leurs copains de quartier
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
allons voter ce sous-amendement qui est
un bouge et qui ne n'importe pas notre
conviction sur le reste du texte merci à
la parole
merci monsieur le président donc je
remercie d'abord le ministre de nous
avoir donné des chiffres clairs ainsi
chacun peut se faire son idée en
particulier sur cette histoire de
vaccination des plus jeunes
je remercie aussi madame la présidente
alors je note la proposition je note que
c'est un pas vers une partie de la
majorité est un pas vers l'opposition je
le dis parce que il me semble que c'est
important en démocratie on fonctionne
par des compromis et donc je reconnais
ce pas là aussi nous allons voter
cet amendement et ce sous amendement ça
n'en porte pas forcément notre
conviction pour le reste du texte bien
sûr puisque c'est un amendement pour
nous de repli est encore de repli savait
que nous n'avons pas voté le poste
sanitaire et que nous n'avons pas
l'intention de voter le pass vaccinale
mais je reconnais votre votre pas et je
le prends en compte
merci alors monsieur monsieur brindeau à
la parole
oui merci monsieur le président c'est
l'honneur de l'assemblée nationale
parfois de savoir se rassembler sur
des questions aussi importantes que
l'intérêt supérieur de l'enfant et moi
je me félicite que cet accord qui est
intervenu soit un accord qui rassemble
des bords de la france un soumises
jusqu'au républicain
parce que et c'était l'objet de tous les
amendements qu'ils étaient déposées on
voit bien la situation dans laquelle se
trouvaient les enfants qui parlent le
choix de leurs parents ne pouvaient être
vaccinés qui se trouvait de fait exclus
d'activité
d'épanouissement personnel que ce soit
des activités scolaires et périscolaires
ou extrascolaires des activités
sportives ou des activités culturelles
et désormais même si c'est jusqu'à 16
ans nous aurions préféré jusqu'à 18 mai
nous nous rangeons évidemment à la
proposition faite par le sous amendement
gouvernemental avec la logique
d'ailleurs qu'il poursuit du fait que
les enfants de 16 à 18 ans peuvent se
faire vacciner même sens la vie de leurs
parents nous nous rangeons à cette
logique là avec la précaution que le
décret puisse bien intégrer toutes les
activités extrascolaires c'est à dire la
participation à un club sportif et pas
seulement le nss la totalité des
activités culturelles et sportives que
les jeunes de cet âge là peuvent exercer
une multi avons évidemment le
sous-amendement et l'amendement merci
et différents groupes que je souhaitais
ont pu s'exprimer
donc madame la présidente en avant
madame la présidente ou vtx tué madame
la président de la commission
merci beaucoup monsieur le président non
juste quelques mots je devrais remercier
chacun des groupes présents dans
l'hémicycle ce soir vous avez grâce à
votre esprit d'ouverture permis ce
consensus ce consensus qui est important
merci à monsieur le ministre d'avoir été
à l'écouté du parlement je crois que
quand nous fonctionnons comme ça nous
honorons notre mandat est donc
simplement merci à tous et j'espère que
nous voterons cette sous-amendement et
cet amendement dans un mail unanimité
merci
alors mes chers collègues mes chers
collègues
nous sommes dans une discussion commune
ce dont nous vous nous venons parler le
plus amendement c'est au terme d'une
discussion commune on doit donc repasser
tous les amendements évidemment ce
qu'ils veulent et retiré peuvent les
routiers ce qu'ils veulent les conserver
sont conservés y aura donc un vote alors
le
233 et retiré madame le grip on est
d'accord le 2 138 monsieur jumelles
retirer n'ont pas retiré donc on votera
les 305 bon peu importe pour les autres
puisqu'ils sont identiques donc on va
d'abord voter sur cette série
de 238 donc c'était là un vote
électronique négatif commission négatif
gouvernement nous votons sur cette série
de 138 puisqu'il ya un maintenu c'est un
vote là électronique un chacun regagner
sa place
le scrutin est ouvert
c'est le vote n'est des votes de
monsieur l'amendement de monsieur
jumelles qui l'a maintenue dans un
endroit donc au vote sur cet amendement
défavorable commission gouvernement faut
suivre
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici les résultats
vote entre 188 exprime entre 519
majorité 190% 30 compte 249 donc rejetée
donc on a passé cette série 2e série
d'amendements identiques
là aussi ça donnait lieu à un vote
électronique s'ils sont maintenus le 57
et retiré on est d'accord
maintenu maintenu le 92 maintenu le 126
maintenu le 237 jumelles maintenu le 446
maintenu soutenu ce monsieur kim keller
de 542 retirer alors vous seriez un vote
électronique
donc négatif sur un manga nick avis
négatif de la commission du gouvernement
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin
est clos
voici les résultats
votants 387 x400 sauf 18 majorité 190%
30 contre 248 rejetée nous allons
maintenant aborder le 628 madame il tire
mais hier il est retiré retirer
le 509 n'a pas été défendu le 717 madame
bonheur il est maintenu donc là c'est un
vote à main levée qui est pour les 717
qui est contre rejeté
alors le
le 310 est maintenue madame bonnaire qui
est pour
ma lever qui est contre rejeté nous
retrouvons une logique d'un de vote
électronique le si ce monsieur est de l
île est maintenue maintenu le 8
mai tenue mais je me donnais
le 15 sept avaient pas été défendu le 68
maintenu monsieur cinieri sommes
quatorze maintenu monsieur mines
monsieur breton cheminots également 225
donc ils sont maintenus il ya un vote
électronique
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici les résultats
votants 70 explique 62 majorité 182% 15
contre 247 rejetée alors nous en
arrivons maintenant au doublé amendement
645 sous amendement gouvernemental
numéro
2 726 on met d'abord aux voix le
sous-amendement c'est un vote à main
levée malgré le sous-amendement donc
cédé sous amendement gouvernemental et
dit favorable la commission qui et pour
qui et compte adopter
maintenant nous allons voter sur
l'amendement 645 ainsi sous-amendé donc
évidemment avis favorable de la
commission du gouvernement chacun
regagne sa place
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos voici les résultats
votants 397 exprimé du 388
majorité 195 pour 386 contre 2 donc
l'amendement ainsi que l'amendé est donc
adopté
alors on continue mes chers collègues
tout ça entre parenthèses démontre
l'intérêt des sous-amendements je vous
rappelle que certains voulaient
supprimer des sous-amendements il ya peu
de temps un
le 113 le 113 monsieur di filippo
mais il n'est pas défendu
il est dépassé dit filippo vous avez la
parole
qu'il défend à la
ben oui mais il faut fait le tour pas
fait de tour
monsieur di filippo rejoint le micro
et il faut le défendre mais je lis
philippot là
monsieur le président je ne suis pas
responsable de la gestion des entrées
des sorties dans cet hémicycle vous le
pensez vous le pensez bien
merci beaucoup en tout cas de me laisser
là la parole n'a mandement qui est
important puisque on le constate et vous
le nombre et remettre et passer en
question monsieur le ministre l'activité
physique a des bienfaits pour la santé y
compris dans la lutte contre le coc vide
elle nous rend moins susceptibles faire
des formes graves elle permet de
stimuler les défenses immunitaires et
donc à chaque fois qu'on met l'activité
physique et sportive des français
notamment des plus jeunes et de tous les
français en général entre parenthèses on
cause des difficultés très importantes
pour nos associations pour nos clubs
sportifs mais aussi c'est une bombe à
retardement sanitaires vous connaissez
vous même et dangers de la sédentarité
pour notre population pour les
générations qui viennent alors le but de
cet amendement c'est tout simplement de
retirer les lieux de pratique sportive
est bien de la nécessité de présenter un
pass vaccinant
merci donc de 382 et défendu avis de la
commission défavorable gouvernement
défavorable en réponse monsieur di
filippo vous avez la parole oui je pense
que c'est un sujet important
il faut savoir que l'année dernière 15 %
de français en moi ont pu pratiquer une
activité physique c'est quand même
quelque chose qui en tant que ministre
de la santé doit vous interpellez parce
que je crois que ça ne fera pas beaucoup
réagir madame roxana maracineanu qui
semblent eux et bien simplement se
satisfaire de la proche des des jeux
olympiques de paris mais ne pas
s'occuper ni de nos associations ni de
la pratique sportive en france alors
j'aurais bien aimé avoir une réponse est
bien sûr c'est sûr c'est malheureusement
et bien sûr ses méfaits du coc vite pour
nos associations pour les pratiques
sportives je crois que c'est des choses
que nous devons absolument est
résolument combat et permettent en
toutes circonstances et en tous lieux
une pratique sportive pour nos
concitoyens
malin pyatt
merci monsieur le président a vu la
discussion en commission en parlant des
enfants monsieur le ministre
vous êtes le premier à nous expliquer
que les personnes vaccinées qui se
retrouvent
hospitalisé que ce soient enfants ou
adultes sont des personnes qui souffrent
de comorbidité est l'une des premières
comorbidités c'est l'obésité et quel est
le meilleur moyen de prévention pour
protéger nos concitoyens de l'obésité
c'est la pratique sportive et empêcher
nos concitoyens d'autant plus dont
vacciner de faire du sport et donc de se
protéger d'une obésité qui les
conduirait en réanimation c'est c'est
totalement
vraiment dangereux pour eux d'autant
plus qu' on peut leur demander de faire
un test
veut présenter un test négatif avant
pour protéger protéger soi et protéger
les autres vraiment c'est de la
prévention
faire du sport dans notre pays c'est
aussi protéger nos concitoyens d'une co
morbidités dont on entend tellement
parler
donc je me revois ces différents
amendements négatif commission
gouvernement le 113 qui est pour contre
rejeté de 382 qui est pour contre je
t'ai
défendu à la barre
le pass vaccinale si par malheur devait
entrer en vigueur s'appliquera à
l'ensemble des lieux de la vie
quotidienne de nos compatriotes mais
également transport inter régionaux sans
tarder sur l'absence attardé sur
l'absence de logique évident à
l'appliquer aux trajets tgv entre région
mais pas au métro et aux pères et aux
rer dans lequel le virus lui a sûrement
circulait suffisamment selon vous malgré
la très forte promiscuité
accepter de devoir justifier d'un pass
vaccinale pour être en capacité de
pandas prêtés régionale constitue une
véritable discrimination
de nombreux français sont contraints de
prendre des tgv par exemple ne serait ce
que pour se rendre sur leur lieu de
travail
comment justifier des lords privé
certains de nos concitoyens non vaccinés
d'un outil impératif à l'exercice de
leur activité professionnelle
vous voyez chers collègues l'absurdité
de telles mesures et au delà le danger
que représente pour bon nombre de
français la lutte contre l'épidémie ne
peut justifier tout télé striction il
est temps de remettre un peu de raison
dans le débat public il respecter chacun
donné perdant par le commission
défavorable du gouvernement monsieur
miller à la parole
oui je voudrais insister sur la
nécessité de préserver par dessus tout
et j'aimerais même parler de
sanctuarisation
de l'activité sportive les activités
sportives pour les enfants mais aussi
pour les adultes et pour nombre de
publics sont salutaires et j'ai eu
l'occasion de produire un rapport
parlementaire avec ma collègue monique
outil qui met en avant le concept de
sportica mans et ce concept de sportica
mans il doit être respecté
parce que c'est la pratique du sport
c'est la meilleure défense immunitaire
contre les beaucoup de maladies et
notamment lakovic 19 donc il aurait été
contradictoires de ceux de mettre en
avant la volonté de mener des politiques
publiques pour préserver la santé et en
même temps de limiter de restreindre
l'accès aux lieux de pratique sportive
voilà mon point de vue donc je défends
je soutiens tous les amendements et
toutes les positions qui vont dans ce
sens
merci j'ai mes 2 883 qui est pour
contre jeter 400 ch défendu
défavorable commission défavorable
gouvernement mais se voit qui est pour
contre il est rejeté prochaine séance ce
soir à 21h30 débat sur l'application la
loi visant à élargir contre les
violences au sein de la famille suite du
projet loi renforçant les outils de
gestion la crise sanitaire la séance est
levée